tenemos aquí unas manzanas y unas
naranjas y lo que quiero que pensemos es
cuál es la proporción de manzanas
la proporción de manzanas en relación
con naranjas y para aclarar lo que
quiero decir la proporción nos da una
relación entre las cantidades de dos
cosas diferentes y hay algunas maneras
en que podemos especificar esto podemos
contar literalmente el número de
manzanas 1 2 3 4 5 6 tenemos 6 manzanas
y la relación es de 6
y aquí tenemos que saber cuántas
naranjas tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
la relación es 6 a 9 la proporción de
manzanas en relación con naranjas es 6 a
9 y podemos usar diferentes notaciones
también podemos escribirlo de esta
manera 62 puntos 9 y esto lo leemos 6 a
9 la proporción es 6 a 9 y una manera de
pensar en la relación de manzanas y
naranjas es cuantas manzanas tenemos
para un cierto número de naranjas y
cuando pensamos de esta manera podría
reducir estos números como seguramente
ya lo han imaginado y vemos que 6 y 9
son divisibles entre 3 y así como
reducimos fracciones también podemos
reducir proporciones
así que dividimos 6 y 9 entre 3 estos
dos números se pueden dividir entre 36
dividido entre 13 es 26 entre 3 es 2 y 9
dividido entre 3 es 3
así que podemos decir que la proporción
entre manzanas y naranjas es de 2 a 3 o
podemos usar esta anotación 2 a 3 2 a 3
y esto tiene sentido si lo pensamos de
esta manera fíjense bien dividimos todo
en tres grupos
un grupo dos grupos
y tres grupos iguales podemos ver que en
cada uno de estos grupos por cada dos
manzanas tenemos tres naranjas por cada
dos manzanas tenemos tres naranjas por
cada dos manzanas tenemos tres naranjas
para revisar una vez más la proporción
de manzanas en relación con naranjas es
dos a tres por cada dos manzanas tenemos
tres naranjas
también podemos pensar en esto de otra
manera cuál es la proporción de naranjas
en relación con manzanas
la proporción de naranjas en relación
con manzanas
y básicamente lo que tenemos que hacer
es cambiar los números fíjense que en
este ejemplo de arriba dice manzanas en
relación con naranjas y la proporción es
6 a 9 o 2 a 3 porque reducimos estos
números
y aquí queremos la proporción de
naranjas en relación con manzanas y lo
que tenemos que hacer es cambiar los
números aquí tenemos 9 naranjas por cada
6 manzanas y entonces podemos decir que
la proporción es de 9 a 6 la proporción
es de 9 a 6
y lo podemos reducir por cada tres
naranjas vamos a tener dos manzanas por
cada tres naranjas tenemos dos manzanas
fíjense esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tenemos aquí pero cuando tenemos
manzanas a naranjas la proporción es
seis a nueve seis manzanas por cada
nueve naranjas y acá abajo la proporción
es de naranjas a manzanas y vemos que es
de nueve a seis nueve naranjas por cada
seis manzanas y también podemos decir
que por cada tres naranjas tenemos dos
manzanas